c'est une ville fantôme
interdite au civil comme aux
journalistes par l'armée ukrainienne
nous y entrons avec des volontaires qui
veulent nous montrer que les russes ont
bien été chassés d'ici de macquarie fpt
ukraine
il nous encerclaient et sont entrés même
dans le centre-ville on les a repoussés
à l'extérieur il ya deux jours
les ukrainiens ont replanté leurs
couleurs dans 80% de macquarie fpt les
combats ont été féroces
ce véhicule blindé ukrainien en témoigne
ils sont posés quelques fleurs en
hommage aux soldats morts nous roulons
dans un silence pesant jusqu'au centre
ville
nous sommes place de la mairie regardez
ces déserts mais il y a des drapeaux
ukrainien celui ci a été remis en place
sur le centre culturel
l'armée russe se bat à mac arrive pour
le contrôle de cette autoroute en
lisière de la ville elle mène tout droit
à kiev par l'ouest
l'un des chars russes est resté là
détruit par les combats la contre
offensive menée par l'armée ukrainienne
a donc bien fait reculer ici l'armée de
vladimir poutine le maire de macquarie
ce ne peut pas entrer dans sa ville
comme il veut il nous montre aux abords
les derniers bombardements russes
clairement je voulais finir de nous
couper les communications
des véhicules blindés brûlé l'armée
ukrainienne n'a pas encore remporté de
victoire totale à macquarie mais cette
bataille pourrait être le premier signe
que les russes ne sont pas invincibles
[Musique]